he understood if he gets it right there
but yeah in the end he compromised well
the result the outcome was successful
but yeah I think Fabiano of course you
lose the game you're very disappointed
but he knows he was drawing that
position sure I think it's extremely
difficult for him to get back I mean in
ten minutes knowing that he had really
very close chance there yeah but of
course with such a short time on your
clock it's extremely difficult but what
about today yes today because so far we
had the repetition of opening of game
ville and but still there is a little
difference and black has this pawn on a4
which can be a problem I think later on
I didn't like this move c6 because after
takes legs I thought this was the
critical move I also think is the
critical move but simply after rook c8
you have known id5 because of Queenie
for this is the problem okay
and actually it would force white to
take on e7 take and then you're going to
preserve the pawn on c6 so this is
something why just simply cannot be
playing okay so that's the that's the
issue so after rook F c8 what does
Fabiano has in mind to play Queen b5 but
this is carry on the Kings side I mean
Venus well I mean okay worst case we
simply give the pawn and play Knight d5
or something but obviously you can't
after death you just lost it's just
really just a pawn down okay I still
think I agree move okay copy 424 I like
because definitely his aim is to put his
knight on d5 but what is he going to do
on Queen f3 he wants to go Queen d5 very
tricky very nice way of solving their
situation okay let's go back let's just
I'm I think Queen c4 because it's very
important for one moment it feels a
little flimsy I wonder if we can do
something here what about black playing
okay five okay actually everything is
about the d5
square right now this reminds me of all
those fresh new curves and all those
night offs I've played over the years
d5 the d5 square yeah the d5 square is
the issue if I mean one day black is
going d5 then you don't want to know
what's happening to white in other hand
it's a big question whether after okay
five
how can white deal against the move
Knight Queen f3 and with all the attacks
on the long diagonal well we should be
six is crucial I think that's the the
main question and let's say Queen f3
if white camp like we need four but
after Queen e4 black is going to be five
basics actually is also I just wanted to
attack and play d5 yeah but I think rule
k-6 is just at least as good okay but
let's go back clock times fifteen four
minus 14 for from point of view of
course it's a very simple idea 97 he
just wants to get get rid of the c6 fast
bone so we play 95 but I think it's it
has to be played and after is there some
force drawer if ok so for example queen
of three castles before and I think it
will be four unless the sacrifice yeah
definitely I think that's his reasoning
yeah but it's it's not necessarily oh I
mean it can be very unpleasant for white
also 9594 sorry if I see just go okay I
was trying to get tricky with rook c6
and Queen see something more forcing but
okay there's always 97 chicks anyway no
no yeah II four as well so I think this
maybe he's thinking well now there are a
lot of moves ofcourse Knight e4 is also
something to consider after the bishop
laughs okay hang on hang on again Queen
f3 I think
and actually there are some tricky ideas
I think that black can take take 95
plate 95 plate yeah
so let's see what he has in mind after
Queen f3 right Bishop h5 is also
something to consider of course for
black and after kinky - to go E for yeah
it looks not so funny for what I'm 95
coming night yes well okay we'll bury my
97 check of course but do you know what
in some ways why is this a surprise that
black is okay these pieces are better
coordinated whose black slacks I don't
know I like very much rights position
but I don't like the King dirty white
everything it's just you should just go
to a 1 and then fine then you're fine
right but the King completely messes it
up yeah but actually blacks position is
so good because of the white weak spots
on g4 h 483 and the problem of the e4
move actually I don't know exactly what
we have a move do we know Bishop a5 is
not played yet not yet but what can y do
I just don't understand really 8 e 4 I
mean is Knight f4 or what is it going to
happen
but Bishop f4 but I don't know it was
very cool but it's not that I'm so happy
about it but I just don't see another
move and we have E for immediately but
actually after E for I would be well of
course ff4 is oh yes but after F for the
problem is be my guest
he's gaining a big temper with 95 I was
wondering for a second to go back on C 3
but actually it's not possible
okay so I think here it goes 93 exactly
so I think you have to castle no
actually it's not over yet because black
has compensation was probably not more
than that right so I think after E for I
think you have to Castle and then after
one of them that's why black didn't play
Bishop a5 so he can play Knight e5 in
Queen h3 and oh you know you give a
check you can give a check the Knights
on d5 is on priests go over immediately
I don't really know what so II fear is
very problematic we could I tell you
what this could be 2-0 easily huh he's
on the edge that's true what about c7
it feels like I should be taking that
with what with Bishop and now somehow 95
Queen d5 no but also Queen e2 was
possible but ok let's go Queen d5 Knight
f3
I know Roxy 7 know if doopsy 7 the Queen
a check first winner a check this is the
problem some some things can go right
for white to but no that's how it seems
that it's it's really shaky with white
so let's say Knight d3 and then King e2
enough shrieking d2 and now if I can say
that he has a piece up it's already
something it's already a big something
but I play rook b8 well I understand
that it's not very nice because take
stakes and Queenie to add and there's
not nice because after Knight move
somewhere down Queen B - well not very
funny not very funny fabby down to C
actually no 9 looks like 9 9 place 13 7
thanks 95 you go well should we go back
to the position actually on the board
this is the position on the board
efore deadly dangerous for right well do
we need to just simply prevent 95 so
well we talked about Bishop f4 I think
you can try to go Bishop d4 it's gone c7
should take c7 no I think there was
actually nothing else to I mean
otherwise you're just having her
addicted to five here we go it's down
the main line
oh yeah critical Oh Queen c3 maybe
what about Queen c3 of course it's not
so much fun to stay in the in the pen
but actually it is very critical at this
point because everything will depend
where he is going to put his screen but
Queen c3 actually unlike you know give a
check yeah in d2 ruby eight right
attacking you I'd say I can go Roxy too
because the rock is on h1 is not hanging
well if I want me to grab material then
of course I could come to see one you
want to grab no no I was off to root be
a crook see - of course I can play well
rugby seven
if I take that night it's going yeah
it's not easy
what else can write the 25 actually was
the move in d5 every checking I mean
that kind of logical ways I'm actually
even Ruby eight is possible straightaway
yeah just to keep it in mind this that
little rook c7 very any even off the
castles wife can go Queen d6 but it's
definitely more dangerous for white
could I wonder instead of route c7 could
we play Queen h3 we need for week we
need for hole do okay you'll be for all
these things I understand my simply a
blunder yep okay so wrong side my point
of view okay so we do have to take on c7
yep so Queen d5 looks of course the the
best option but we checked worried
before if weight 93 but actually I went
King e to I think maybe I should walk in
d2 then I had a check
yeah so I don't even understand why I
didn't go to d2 immediately okay then we
should definitely play a root B eight
instead of checking
crazy tension sitting there and has to
Bobby has to decide where to go with the
King time situation six minutes
remaining
Fabiano 13 minutes for Magnus crazy
crazy I was just just upstairs and
fabiana's parents have arrived in town
and they're looking at the board in a
very tense way I can tell you
understandably so route b8 can we find a
sensible move there is it fond of
ordinal yeah 90999 oh so he's got
night-night
East so what's going on one second he's
Queens on priests 97 is possible yeah we
spotted 97 we get the square right we
just not not be denied Wow well if you
can get away with that that would kind
of solve a lot of problems okay but what
happens kinga CH make 7 ah now this is
awkward because the Queen might not have
a good square he goes to d4 there's a
fork if there's well well well what be
Queen B 5 what do you want yeah there is
not much of an option yeah but then okay
there fuseki 3 is the check there's also
just bear in mind root BAE I don't know
which way round you want to do it but
this looks very very nasty
well I guess both of us would like to
take the black pieces right just in
general you know if you look at a
position and you look at the two kings
and you look at blacks King and you look
at White's King and on that basis alone
yeah it's I'm in this king god I know
ever if it's reaches a castle or
actually its worsening his position th7
played very quickly by magnets he's
obviously foreseen that the tricky
Knight d5 but actually this looks even
worse than the options that we were
considering because the Queen some you
simply doesn't have a good square Queen
e2 then well check with the night and
you take on d5 for example well this
does not look very promising for right
software saying four minutes for Fabiano
down on time down on position I can't
even see a compromise move this is the
problem what about 1997 anyway Queen f3
I suppose 97 Queen f3 is that winning I
don't know but Fabi is thinking I think
I believe you to go I'm and you come
back for plate sorry it's it's my it's
my turn to be booted out you do it was a
pleasure as over these lines not too
much fun for you take us through the
rest of the game Thanks so now it seems
Fabiano is really having a very
difficult moment and within minutes we
might see a very sad Fabiano because he
is very much on the edge of having
problems in this game again and if he is
going to be losing 2-0 then it's her
match would be over pacing well
basically it's almost impossible weird
that's what he has to deal with it is
definitely something very very very
unpleasant softly saying what he's
having on the board you can see on his
face also he's very unhappy Magnus is
feeling extremely comfortable well
especially this position and having ten
extra minutes
it is something incredible two and a
half minutes left for the Challenger and
he is in trouble he has an extra piece
but his King is going to be suffering as
you mentioned they I heard if you liked
White's position if it wasn't for the
King if the King was on a1 but it cannot
really travel to that a1 square
unfortunately that's not how chess works
well I think this this is where things
are good chances flying flying away from
Fabi to get the crown for the American
since he has been doing so well during
three weeks of the vultures championship
match hasn't lost a single game Magnus
can say the same of course but it seemed
that Fabi except for Game one which was
a miracle scape by the Challenger
afterwards he has been doing very well
and he had Fabiano counter resets to
zero for Magnus Carlsen
fantastic game by Magnus he played
extremely well though Fabi could could
not not give a good challenge she was
too aggressive in playing the c5 c6 I
mean as he couldn't make Knight d5 work
immediately it meant that it was c5 I
think it was simply not a good move
because it was too early before having
his King castled
after cast so here c6 I think it was too
much it was opening up the position too
much and black had simply so much play
immediately so he should have gone for
the sole at sea takes d6 and the well it
seems like he couldn't handle the having
the opportunity to play and fight well
Magnus was absolutely right to do all
these draws even it was it was unusual
and not understandable for for most of
us that what he didn't move game 12 but
it seems like he was so sure of himself
that he will be out think Fabiano in the
in the rapid games and but I'm kind of
surprised that it got it went it seemed
so easy of course it yes it's never so
easy but from outside we can say that
it's somehow went very smooth and
actually Fabiano could not really get
over on game one especially that he felt
that he had very close in having drawing
chances and simply couldn't recover in
ten minutes
and and in this game he was completely
unbalanced there was a problem with of
course the rapid playoffs and how the
system works that there's only ten
minutes between the two games as you
mentioned but I also think for example
this opening we had in game 12 as well
this h4 h5 structure and and really it
was interesting that during the game I
was when analyzing I was absolutely not
a favor of having this with one because
there are so many big points and squares
appearing after age 4 and checking with
the engine the engine was so optimistic
about it and maybe this is also
something 101 of the hole in the may be
the only hole in fabi's preparation it
was that in this specific line after the
97 playing gauge for maybe objectively
it has a point the engine has has its
point but he couldn't deal with it in in
practically in a practical position
somehow in the game he couldn't really
play it well the structure and in both
games he went wrong in different ways
but in one game him kicker said long and
that was the problem in this game he's
left his king so somehow he couldn't
fill the dynamics of this position if at
all it is good for white another
situation is of course extremely
difficult of Fabiano Magnus Carson is
half a point away from defending his
title if he makes a draw in game 3 the
match is over we will not see four games
because two and a half points is the one
that's needed two and a half points and
Magnum scores and keeps his crown we
will be back with that K but before that
we have an interview with our special
guest Lucy Hawking Lucy how is it for
you you know the tens how did you feel
to make the first move a lot of players
there you know they're nervous how do
you feel about it yourself there's an
incredibly electric atmosphere there it
was so tense it was really most exciting
ten seconds ever I've really enjoyed it
and I wanted to say I could stay and do
all the moves for them but I was only
doing the first move you know actually
in a Great Britain last time last year's
you know they're trying to involve a
chest in education system what do you
think of it and what is your opinion it
does it helpful for kids I think it's
very I think the possibilities of chess
and education are very exciting there's
something really interesting research
showing that chess for young people
increases creativity it helps with
spatial awareness logical deduction
maths reading but also chess is very
strongly associated with children with
very high IQs but there's some
interesting research that shows that
chess will help kids who are less
motivated to progress with maths could
also be helpful for kids with ADHD and
can even show marked improvement in kids
with special educational needs so I
think that shows it's really across the
board it's a universally beneficial
educational intervention I know that
your father he didn't play maybe just
professionally but he still was involved
with this game is that true that's right
I used to play chess when I was a little
girl I would play chess with my father
and of course because I was a little
girl I didn't realize he was a genius
and I couldn't understand why he always
won I know that you have some small
thing uniques me with you today
can you show it to us yes I've got this
picture here which is an oil painting of
my father with my two brothers he's
playing chess they're playing chess
together my brothers are there with my
father now this painting actually hasn't
really been seen since around the 1980s
it was just we just found it again very
very recently and it's really beautiful
and you can see the three of them
engaged in this activity I think my
little brother is playing chess and my
older brother is looking on and perhaps
he's helping my little brother with his
game were you playing very often with
your father yeah yes I did I played
chess with my father or not he taught me
to play chess and as I said I was just
always mystified by the fact that he
always won I didn't understand it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- Carson starts the rapid break tiebreak
with two out of two he only needs half a
point more to defend his title and he's
gonna have the white pieces in Game
three it seems that he is almost there
he has almost done it we haven't
expected this this crushing start from
the world champion yes he it's his day
it's very clear and he can say that
everything went according to plans right
after game time yeah it's it's very
interested - interesting to see him
coming back to himself to really perform
as he usually used to perform right and
so it it was very interesting to see
Game one specially how it can unfold it
because that was kind of interesting the
opening choice the middle game the
crucial moment he he pointed out he felt
it he was spending quite a lot of time
on that point and yeah it seems like
that his his his much more here in the
game right now and it's a shorter game
which I think he's very happy about that
the game is not lasting five six seven
hours and so game one was was somewhat
very important already for a match and
it seems like for Fabiano this opening
actually at the two versus the end of
the match there is an opening
preparation which is which is actually
leaving him with not with opportunities
but somehow he's he's getting lost in
this kind of position at least he did in
game 12 and also now in the second game
of the rapid yes it's interesting that
is the same variation same swash nico
with 97 and both cases it was
troublesome for yeah I mean the the bone
structure it was something that it was
not possible for him to handle and I
think it's so complicated and it's it's
it's so rich in plans in ideas where you
put your king after every move there are
different things happen new
opportunities arise and I think simply
it's much easier to play it with the
black pieces because with the black
pieces you have a much more
straightforward idea and plans that you
have your problem having your your phone
on h5 which can be vulnerable so you
have to look after it
but once black is really protecting and
once he's coming out with his pawn to e4
and the g6 bad night or passive night
can be coming into the game to e5 or
just the threat of it it it is very
difficult and actually crashing ik of
itself it's very much that kind of
opening that it happens many times that
you think you're doing fine with white
and actually somehow then the dynamic
changes and those Queen King side pawns
of black start marching f v e4 and some
of the white and black squares also can
be very bad or very weak from white
point of view suddenly especially after
the the ponies it takes d5 taken a move
7 so it is very difficult opening and
and Magnus showed why White has to be so
careful in making pawn moves already in
the early part of the game on the Kings
side not cancelling but they're making
weaknesses
I was also checking in the meantime the
hashtag Hassan Cara 2018 and of course
most of the comments are about Magnus
keeping his title for instance cielito
sanchez saying to zero now with Magnus
leading only a draw to retain the crown
Suren wrote yes looks like that costume
will keep the chest grin for another two
years
almost there half a point is missing but
most most of the tweets are about this
and of course you can still send your
message to us by using the hashtag
Carson Corona 2018 I think no one even
the biggest at Magnus fans expected this
impressive start to zero and only half a
point away from defending well I think
not many people expected that it was a
scenario
- Stu zero as a start for Magnus but it
was an alternative of course he's a
exceptionally good player in rapid and
it's not only that that he's very good
in rapid he has all the self confidence
that he can make it which is very
important because that's what I felt in
the classical game part of the match
that somehow he was unbalanced he didn't
he was he might have been frustrated
with the opening preparation also
admitting it that Fabiano's preparation
was better he out prepared him
practically so he didn't really get the
games he wanted he didn't get advantage
he didn't post too much of a trouble for
Fabiano and that must have been quite
annoying and from this point of view
when you don't get anything out of the
opening and you see your opponent is
much better or better prepared it seems
like the match is very long right
because every day you're going to meet
him with the right or with the black
cover colour in other hand in rapid he
didn't lose his self-confidence he I
think from the beginning he knew that
six six is not a bad result at all I
mean he is going to be more the favorite
in the rapid if they enter into the
playoffs than in the classical game and
it shows that he really understood where
is his strength is and that's why he
decided game eleven twelve even though
of course it doesn't mean that we will
understand his decision but but he seems
to be right what he did at least from
from reality point of us he started with
two out of two and now there is a very
very little chance that Fabiano can come
back to kick back because in because of
everything right I mean after 2-0 it's
only 1/2 a point missing for caution out
of two games to keep even if he lost
game three join the last round in game
of course if Fabiano would win game 3 I
mean
I mean then it would be another story
because again after that Fabiano is
playing with the right pieces then
anything can happen but but this game
he shouldn't lose safe with the white
pieces yeah so it will be very
interesting to see whether he goes c4
again
which I would think he will because now
that the drone is yeah
efore is also a good choice so it is
very difficult for Fabiano that how he
will be able to create chances for
himself because being to be 2 points
behind and draw is enough it is it is
almost we can say it's an impossible
journey for him yes unfortunately it's
very unlikely that the changer can
bounce back we are about to start game 3
- Carson is already at the board and we
are waiting for Fabian or to return to
the box as well
of course also interesting to know that
man Wisconsin in general should be very
confident not only about the rapid and
blitt skills he has but playoffs in
general he I believe he hasn't lost a
playoff tiebreak since 2006 which is an
amazing record yeah somehow he has a
great mindset for that I think he very
much fills the positions the time the
crucial moment and and there where the
opponents are going to go wrong or what
kind of decisions in positions they have
to to make decisions and it can be very
difficult for them and I think we can go
back to I think this was was saying just
be kind it if for indeed the petrov
would have been not so lucky decision
for Fabiano he has to win this game
therefore he switches to the sicilian as
black for the first time yeah absolutely
now it it it's a situation that he just
has to come up with interesting ideas
unexpected ideas and somehow confused
Magnus that he might be get unbalanced
for whatever reason the maratti setup is
but Magnus chooses see foreign data we
can play d4 yeah it will be of course
extremely difficult even to create some
middle game very work it can be chances
for black because at this level if
you're playing with the right pieces
usually it should not give you very big
difficulty to make a draw but ok let's
see what we are going to see in the game
knight c6 d4 C takes d4 Knight takes d4
and well actually it's not a classical
way of Marazzi because actually the bone
is not on d6 yet so black can possibly
play Bishop b4 objectively but I think
after Bishop before white will just go
dito so Magnus is ready to exchange
every piece in order to get one step
forward to keep his crown and make the
draw in this game he will definitely not
take any risk he will just play by
intuition these positions and looking
forward to stabilize his position so it
is very difficult for black how to do
play for win right Knight f6 is of
course possibility for now this this is
not possible to play e5 because of Queen
a5 in these positions there is always
this trick but this is not going to be
happening and black played Bishop c5
Bishop c5
so the question is how oops sorry this
is the position we have so now Magnus is
possibly thinking about taking on c6
this is of course one of the idea to be
extremely solid and I think this is this
is something he might be hesitating it
is a very straightforward telling that I
don't want too much in this game in
other hand he's not shy as we saw with
the draw first in the in the games which
was not even necessarily so obvious so
96 is something I think that he is
considering also Knight b3 he's in other
way of reacting and then black will be
playing either Bishop a4 or going back
most likely to e7 but let's see what he
is going to be up to Jonathan Tisdale
Grand Master Jonathan is that from the
press room is saying on Twitter I was
going to joke that Magnus seems to let
loose as soon as he doesn't have to keep
score of the game as you see that they
don't have to write down the moves but
the arbiters do it for them and then he
adds of course but it is probably that
in rapid he has no time to generate
doubts and his intuition is more fully
switched on we have definitely witness
the world champion not being so
confident about his game in the
classical part of the match and now he
is a full beast mode that is for sure
yeah definitely he played in a very good
style game and and actually we have
night c2 on the board interesting that
he chose this line but it's it's not
nothing risky for white knight of 693 I
guess or black will be playing more to
Knight ge7 trying to go out of the
of that more classical way of playing
this these structures and yeah it will
be it is a very very difficult moment
for Fabiana I mean it is impossible to
turn things back after having to zero
you're playing with the black pieces but
in other hand it must be said that he
did not win a single game in the match
right yeah I mean no nothing classical
nor in in rapid of course it would be a
fantastic turn if he would be able to
punch back in this game but definitely
he will need the help of Magnus as well
yes unfortunately for the Challenger is
highly unlikely and therefore for
instance are some of the predictions are
already about Magnus winning yes another
game for instance grandmaster jonathan
rosen he tweeted I predict three zero
and there Magnus stands on the table and
roars of course I mean when you have to
win and this is the case of Fabiano and
I think he still under the shock of
having to zero that he lost both games I
mean it can easily be that he's going to
lose this game again because what can he
lose right I mean Joanne lost it's
exactly the same thing yeah yeah
absolutely
how would you play this variation if you
had to go all-in as black well first of
all in one hand you have to play like a
normal game but of course Fabian Magnus
will be going for simplification I mean
later on he will be playing I think
Bishop III trying to exchange the bishop
mid like well I think 96 or 97 Queen b6
maybe is a try as for now Bishop e3 is
not possible because the b2 is would be
under attack but I would think that
right would be going Queen d2 and
later trying to go b3 and Bishop b2 and
also Knight c3 where Knight a for could
be unpleasant threat
I like generally putting the Queen on
basics and Rockman b6 is an idea Knight
f6 97 but if he goes just the the
patterns then then I'm not sure he will
be able to create for himself any idea
he and I see three immediately played by
- cos and cos da King side
yeah Bishop III yeah yeah of course it's
it's a very solid game for White Witch
Magnus choose to play and it is very
difficult decision what black can do
because of course if he's just taking on
e3 it takes he's going to play these six
white goes Queen d2 and be able to just
to develop Bishop seed be to cast so he
will put his rooks to D 1 and C 1 it it
would be the biggest surprise if black
could do anything
so black played b6 be sixes is played by
about black pieces it has an idea that
if let's say white would be taking on c5
which I doubt that he will do but he may
even here of course it's very difficult
for black to play for a win as white can
go Queen d2 let's say later on he's
going to go b3 white is going to have
rook on Devon he will develop Bishop e2
castle and and the d6 square is also
something that can be annoying for black
so it's a question how white wants to
continue but for the moment he he keeps
the position by playing Bishop e2 we
should be 7-day developing and probably
white will be just castling here but of
course Bishop c5 is always an option
and after d c5 let's say white would be
going Queen d6 then well Queen a5 is the
move now black would be threatening mid
94 Casso but it's it's I mean it's very
difficult for black even I'm not even
sure that black is not worse but
probably he can go route d8 with the
idea to kick out the Queen with 98 but
we have Gossow of course he wants to
keep
position for a moment and black is not
playing d6 which is completely
understandable he wants to keep his bone
on d7 and played Queen e7 Black has
practically no problem but that's in
this position to create chances so that
that's why it is difficult I'm expecting
Queen d2 with white from the white side
where after I think black will try to go
Knight e5 possibly to open up his
diagonal with the bishop and try to
attack on e4 indeed Queen d2 isn't and
Leto is on the board these are all very
typical moves in in this line and later
on the rocks will be coming into the
game most likely rook to d1 from f1 the
other one will go to c1 white can also
play a 3 and B 4 to strengthen his
position and when the e4 pawn is very
much attacked then possibly f3 is also
something white can be playing it is
extremely difficult to crack White's
position usually it can be a long game
after f3 black can go King h8 and g5
sometimes in g4 but I think they'll
still have to wait for that until it
happens
rook d8 black is preparing kind of to be
playing d5 at some point in a good
version after he can move his knight
let's say to e5 and then play d5 open up
the diagonal so it's a logical way of of
playing but I think white will be going
rook F d1 and already after that white
will be really all Bishop c5 immediately
because white is really preparing to
exchange the bishop and after that play
Queen d6 also trying to exchange Queens
some curious if he goes rook 81 or rooks
FD 1 because that
might be also a question and he goes who
have t11 rook fd1 well it's definitely
not a position which you want to have
after losing two games it's it is very
difficult to create chances the best he
can do is try to not to exchange pieces
Fabiano maybe 98 trying to stop the
possibility of exchanges on d6 95 is
something I would consider here yeah we
think 95 can be he has just paid 95
exactly as you might be for the blacks
position is pretty active and all the
pieces are standing perfectly healthy
the Queen on e7 and the rock on d8 is
definitely preparing the possibility
that eventually black can be pushing d5
but of course d5 is maybe is going to be
enough only to equalize the game but the
main question is whether black can put
any pressure on white so Magnus can
spend some time he can make a decision
whether he wants to go on simplifying or
if black can make Magnus hesitate on
anything that's the maximum so far he
can he can get out of this situation I
think well Fabiano at least has managed
to make - sink into a deeper thought
process to his once again back to this
interesting a new way of Magnus poses I
think because I have a we have seen
Magnus in so many tournaments but this
one when he's holding his head with two
hands
most covering his face is not the usual
Magnus
well now white can for example take on
c5 and if and actually he just took
because after Queen c5 black will be
going right will be going I think Queen
d4 so actually black to be take c5 it's
very important for black that for the
moment Queen d6 is not possible because
takes takes and then black can take a
pawn which well after a pawn is the
phone right so white would not go up in
d6 but he can go the simple Queen e3
with the idea of later on just doubling
the rook and being extremely solid the
see tonight is kind of important because
if black would go knight c6 and 94 which
might be coming later that black goes
back knight c6 at one point not now
because II five would be coming but just
showing the idea that he can go knight
c6 later at one point play e5 and go
Knight d4 this can be one of the plans
for black and probably he should try
something like this because if you go d5
then actually that that would be not
something black can be praying for a win
so let's see how Magnus will decide if
he goes Queen e3 or he wants to play f4
that's also possible is straight forward
immediately pushing back the night and
then black would be going back actually
this is possible that he can do this and
after that Queen d6 this can be very
tempting way of continuing the game and
simplify the position that can explain
why he was reaching for the Queen and
then he pulled his arm back he's of
course they're calculating whether f4
Queen e3 is a better move once again
this way of almost touching a piece and
then pulling his arm back is also not a
very Magnus like chess and it showed
some doubts during the match especially
in the classical games when he was
hesitating in couple of critical moments
of course there's lots of tension
and even though he has won the first two
games Magnus knows that he still has to
be precise in order to not to give
chances for exactly for that reason that
if 96 he just goes Queen d6 and he's not
going to lose that game black I think
probably should go to g6 and exactly for
the reason that Queen d6 is not possible
because the f4 point would be under
attack
so after Knight g6 Queen III happened
and finally d6 is played in the game
against a five but it was actually
important for y for Fabiano to have f4
and in this way at some point of the
game he can have more power on the long
diagonal in this game so white played
rogue d2 very natural trying to double
the rooks on the d5 which will make of
course things very hard for black to
create any chance in this game because
White's position is extremely tough it's
like a rock you can break it you can do
anything if I does not want to do
anything or he's not ambitious to create
something possibly black and go Bishop
c6 with the idea later to go Queen b7
but for sure black right is going to go
route d1 and if let's say queen b7 which
may be too early but probably black
should be playing Queen c7 first and
then later on to go Rudy 7 go Rudy 8 but
I think we have another move yeah a6 in
principle can be against the move Knight
b5 at some point even though for the
moment I think it was not so important
because the e4 pawn is under attack so
there is not immediate circumstance that
that white could be playing a 6 ok even
when Magnus of course yo KD 1 was
seven Vincey seven generally speaking I
like because if black will be playing
Group D seven defending the d6 the Queen
will be able to have it on B six or a
five but moreover actually the idea
behind Queen c7 is I think that one time
Knight will be able to transpose to c6
and really later on covered this d4
square playing a5 at least he has to try
it right he has to try something I mean
it seems his position playing the World
Championship practically with very very
very slim chance but at least he has to
try it he has to try he'll not have such
a moment for at least for two years that
he can ask Magnus that challenge Magnus
by any means for the crown and now he
has to just try everything he can for a
moment Bishop f3 is not possible because
it could be as healthy move but until
the night is on g6 it is not advice
because black would be playing Knight H
for the chair for a moment it's it's
important for for black to have it - has
played b3 well also actually d5 can be
something Fabiano is looking for six but
for the moment he is trying to make all
the stable moves which can be helpful in
the later phase of the game and h6 is
that kind of move that you're happy to
have it for whenever there is a
background pop problem can occur you
have h6 just in case and yeah for the
for a moment the game is pretty balanced
reports of Tori the Norwegian camp or
some of the Norwegian campus already
started celebrating after game two in
the VIP area of course the fans of
Magnus must be very happy and on the
other hand what a heartbreak for the
Challenger I was going to mention one of
the tweets about this
akshay I said months of preparation and
another is
with the team and playing your a-game in
every match suddenly one day you blunder
some moves and all things fall apart got
to fear for Fabi well that's exactly the
case what is happening but let's face it
if you are a challenger you have to beat
the world champion right and he couldn't
do it he couldn't do it so far he
couldn't win he couldn't convert his
impossible possibility in Game six right
dream section game 8 so he had to yeah
yeah actually I think game 8 should have
been something very painful and that's
how I felt that in that position having
a great advantage on time great
advantage on the chess board just the
the style of the position was also the
initiative if you feel comfortable you
know you feel it that it has to be in
your hand already or so close and that
you allow Magnus to sneak out from that
one that was horrible mistake and
actually the mistake he made this this
crucial h3 move already before Rudy one
was maybe not so perfect but it's it's
very annoying because you ask yourself
if I don't win this down what although
of course Magnus was kicking kicking
himself after Game one but that was the
start of the match it felt like it was
isolated from the rest of them I saw
game 1 - Carson didn't win a completely
winning position he had more time on the
clock he was completely winning he
didn't manage to convert it but from
then on game 2 and the rest of the match
was very balanced but Fabiano having
chances in Game six in game 8 and yeah I
also think that game 8 was more painful
because game 6 and 18 36 only the engine
pointed at them 1836 but game in another
hand we were discussing this after h6 g3
happened which which prepares Y to play
Bishop f3 but in other hand in some
cases it can be weaknesses so black
played roopd 7 Bishop f3 rook e8
interesting that he did not go to d8 but
he went to e8 and
well I think what we were talking about
once Fabiana will have to push some pawn
moves now I think actually he might be
playing for d5 which actually it's maybe
threatening so let's say if just white
was play a3 I just make a stupid move
which is of course it will not happen
but maybe d5 is already something can be
played Knight to e7 he still preparing
even finish 2 and 97 so we are talking
about the the plan which we discussed
previously the black in the long-term he
most likely wants to go to c6 then play
e5 and play Knight d4 and that's why I
think his rookie is important on he aid
because he might be taking with the e
pawn if there is an exchange on d4 but
in the other hand he also might be
thinking to play d5 so both options are
possible but for a moment Queen f2 was
very important actually to go out of
this possible d5 and d4 because if
whenever black is going to be pushing d5
obviously vital or most likely white
will be pushing through with E 5
afterwards so let's see after 97 what is
Magnus is up to he has 14 minutes and
Fabiano has maybe 18 I'm not sure if I
see it correctly
well now it's a question of minutes for
Fabiano there is a concrete idea for
white for example he can go a 5 and
afteri 5 if D takes e5 right can take
Bishop takes b7 Queen takes b7 F takes
e5 and after roopd - white can play rook
takes d2 and 97 so probably this can be
not easy for white because the e5 pawn
can be vulnerable in this position and
then the next moves may be black and go
night g6 and attack while also the Queen
would be standing quite well controlling
the long diagonal but let's see what
white
h3 which is kind of a strange move to me
and black played rope d8 - FG - well of
course these these pawn moves can cause
problem for white only once the position
will be opened by d5 or by any other
means but that's the most likely that d5
can be so but in this position if let's
say black goes d5 then I think white is
just playing e5 and white is kind of
prepared for it because after Knight
would be going back to e8 is not
something that you want to play with
black so much
I mean if Knight e4 then probably
well for now white cannot really take
the phone because there is a phone
hanging here but I think it's not
possible to take it between c5 then
black would be giving a check so let's
see what is happening sorry oh no goes
nice c6 instead of the five we have 96
on the board and he's kind of ready to
play e5 eventually though maybe in the
next move he might be even thinking to
go night before because as the Queen
left the e4 pawn it can be something
let's say King gage - just to show the
the idea and I before can be movies not
that he's threatening with anything but
maybe he can try to provoke Magnus to
play a three or something then he might
be going back but the main idea
generally speaking to play e5 one day I
think but good for Fabiano is that he is
managing to put some time pressure on
Magnus he's down to 13 minutes but the
position is very stable for white the
Marazzi setup is of course famous for
being solid and stable well also the
question is whether Magnus wants to go
at g4 at one point or it was only
prophylactic moves of course h3 because
after h3 he was able to move back his
Bishop to G - so the g4 square is not
possibility to be used by black playing
Knight g4 so this way white is safe
against those moves Kendrick is saying
on Twitter that this isn't going to
happen but if somehow Fabiano Khurana
made this comeback being down two games
the movie would compete in 350 oh let's
move
yeah g4 would be for the - is going for
it he wanted a favor for him actually
I'm not sure he's right at all it's it's
very strange that I thought he he will
not go for g4 you think it's too much
it's kind of strange that he was going
into this very solid
position and now he plays this apone
moves h3g g 3g for it is kind of
extremely interesting for example now if
white would be going rogue d3 in the
night before would cause serious problem
for him because white cannot take this
night because takes and when the night
is moving away then Bishop e4 I'm in the
e4 pawn is under
you
[Applause]
welcome to the 2018 World Chess
Championship a match between the current
world champion Magnus Carlsen and his
challenger Fabiano Khurana today is the
final day playoff since 12 games haven't
brought a single decisive game I'm Anna
Rudolph your host and our chess expert
is once again Judit Polgar the greatest
female player of all time
hi it is so exciting to be here today
especially we are live from London at
the College where the match has been
taking place for three weeks three weeks
of exciting chess fighting spirit but
still no result no decisive result
happen in any single day and this is the
first world chess championship that is
so close that it goes down to playoffs
without anyone winning winning a
classical game how do you see that Judit
well I think we're seeing an exceptional
match from any point of view it's first
of all that I think we never saw such a
close match from point of view that in
rating points there is only three rating
point difference between the two players
which is practically nothing it's only
one game if Fabiana would have been in
the classical game and he would take not
only the lead in the match but also the
ranking he would be number one Saturday
so this is something very special and
this is the reason why actually they are
seeing also so many draws and so
balanced match that none of the players
could make for such a mistake from the
other side that they could complete the
full point of course there was this
famous Game one where Magnus could have
been winning the game and also Fabiano
had in Game six which was not very much
a human opportunity 36 but but generally
speaking it we are we are
now dealing with a match which will make
I think the chess world different
because I think there will be and has to
be some change of rules change change of
something so it could be more appealing
for the media for the people who are not
such a big expert on chess because we
had quite a few interesting moments of
the match if you looking at it from
chess point of view but I think we are
we are going to get back everything on
this specific day what we didn't got the
decisive games in the previous 20 days
right in the 12 games so I'm very much
expecting today that the tension will be
unbearable for the players and I think
actually in the whole building which is
quite big I think everybody is so
excited like sometimes you may forget to
breathe because it will be such a
tension I think at least that's what I'm
expecting and of course as I was a top
player for quite a few years and I
played trance competitive just more than
three decades
I can still of course feel completely
the nerve-racking moments for the player
what they might be going through in
their mind that it's it's not about the
chess knowledge 100% about today today
is about how did you sleep how do you
feel how the stars are spending and so
many small details how your intuition
works today what happens in Game one
whether you're winning and that's how
it's going to be spoiled to draw or
already the first game will be decisive
so every little slightest detail does
count now and both players know it that
this night will be a huge difference how
they sleep or they sleep at all it
depending what will be the outcome we
are very curious to see the players
there will be soon arriving here in the
players box the soundproof box where the
match has been taking place a reminder
on the format of the playoffs is that
first of all we have four rapid
games with the time control of 25
minutes plus 10 second increment with
each move if there is no winner after
for rapid games no result after 2 2 we
would move on to blitz mini matches each
mini match consists of two games one
with white one with the black pieces if
still no result if there's still no
winner in the mini matches of blitz
games 5 minimizes we shall see
after that Armageddon sudden death that
will be the final game I don't think we
will get there that's a bit too much me
we may have a winner after the for rapid
games mangas call someone the rapid
portion in New York against turcica yaki
the first two games there in New York
were drone and he won Game three and
Game four we shall see what happens here
in London well it's it's very clear that
the after game time which was extremely
interesting maybe we can call the most
interesting game of the match with a lot
of tension there and every game it was
changing the evaluation of us here in
the studio but also when you take a look
with engine it's very very very
complicated and surprisingly after that
Magnus kind of decided that he really
wants to go on for the playoffs and
decided in game 11 that he divided
pieces he's not going to play for
anything special he opened with e4 vit
being not very ambitious it was kind of
not a big surprise but a little surprise
to me but I think what made the whole
world to make a big shock in some way it
was game 12 and he was playing the black
face pieces and an actually Fabiano
played very nervously and made serious
mistakes which gave the upper hand for
Magnus in that game but the mindset of
Magnus was so much on focusing just to
make a draw that even though that he had
a fantastic position that you cannot
even dream off practically he
immediately in the first second when he
could offer a draw officially by the
rules it was move 31 he just offered a
draw he was not interest
about giving putting pressure on Fabiano
in that game he just wanted to move on
to today's games playoff because he has
all these self-confidence that now this
is his time to score that was indeed the
case the last two games that his mindset
was to just head for a playoff so many
people have been criticizing - Carson
for this approach including elite
players I'm not going to read out all
the tweets but I was going to mention
Grandmaster yannick palette here's
Tweety because he is basically summing
up what was happening on social media he
said shocking disappointing crisis
punishment only Carson knows why he
offered a draw we can try and guess his
reasons but let's stop judging and
condemning him he'll answer tomorrow
it's a treat to me yesterday obviously
if he doesn't convince he loses the
title yeah I mean that's very clear that
he is being attacked by by many of the
people for the reason that he offered
aggro but let's analyze it a little bit
why is that we are criticizing him for
this right I mean he's the world
champion he knows what he's doing he has
his strategy so we we can't really blame
him completely in principle by the fact
that he offered a draw the reason is why
chess players and professionals are
really surprised and shocked because
first of all it's a trademark of Magnus
Carlsen that he never offers a draw this
is rule number one and right we're
looking Magnus Carlsen not the principle
question whether a draw four is good or
not so the world champion practically
never offers a draw there were I heard
some people discussing also that well
how did he do that because he never does
that how it was so this is one and the
other thing is you know on a high level
that whenever you get a chance you don't
let it go you take it and this was
something that we consider that he had
such a chance to press Fabiano without
too much of a risk that most of us who
were never sitting in Magnus's place
sitting there playing for the title and
keeping his title we would think that we
would be moving on and put extra
pressure on Fabiano
but as his mindset was completely ready
already after game 10 that he wants to
make two draws or at least he's happy
with those two draws he was I think not
even paying attention he was not even
focusing in the game too much it was so
unexpectedly that he got such an
opportunity but Fabiano that he had such
a position with the black pieces that
you know it's like you want to play it
yourself so I think this is the reason
and really we are going to get an answer
today whether he was right or wrong but
definitely from looking at it from
professional aspect most of us think
that it's a very very very surprising
decision which he may
Kendrick is saying on Twitter that this
isn't going to happen but if somehow
Fabiano Caruana made this comeback being
down two games the movie would come oh
nice move yea g44 the - is going for it
he wanted actually I'm not sure he is
right at all it's it's very strange that
I thought he he will not go for g4 you
think it's too much it's kind of strange
that he was going into this very solid
position and now he plays these bone
moves h 3g g 3g for it is kind of
extremely interesting for example now if
white would be going rogue d3 in the
night before would cause serious problem
for him because white cannot take this
night because takes and when the night
is moving away then Bishop e4 I'm in the
e4 pawn is under
you
solid and this is going for it's too
much it's kind of strange that he was
going into this very solid position and
now he plays these bone moves h 3g g 3g
for it is kind of extremely interesting
for example now if white would be going
rogue d3 in the night before would cause
serious problem for him because white
cannot take this night because takes and
when the night is moving away then
Bishop e4 I'm in the e4 pawn is under
this is going for it he wanted a boy
actually I'm not sure he's right at all
it's it's very strange that I thought he
he will not go for a g4 do you think
it's too much it's kind of strange that
he was going into this very solid
position and now he plays this pawn
moves h 3g g 3g 4 it is kind of
extremely interesting for example now if
white would be going rogue d3 in the
night before would cause serious problem
for him because white cannot take this
night because takes and when the night
is moving away then Bishop e4 I'm in the
e4 pawn is under
too much very solid position and now he
plays this pawn moves
h3g g 3g for it is kind of extremely
interesting for example now if white
would be going route d3 in the night
before would cause serious problem for
him because white cannot take this night
because takes and when the knight is
moving away then Bishop e4 I'm in the e4
pawn is under
you
and he's going for it he wanted a feel
for him actually I'm not sure he's right
at all
it's it's very strange that I thought he
he will not go for g4
you think it's too much it's kind of
strange that he was going into this very
solid position and now he plays the pawn
moves h 3g g 3g for it is kind
you